This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In nearly every dimension of our lives, we have two selves. We have the self that knows what the right thing is to do, and then we have, well, ourselves. In high school, we know that hard work and preparation are crucial to success. But when it comes time to choose between study and play, many of us choose the easy path.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。在我们生活的几乎方方面面，我们都有两个自我。一个自我知道什么是正确的事，而另一个自我嘛，就是我们自己。在高中时，我们知道努力和准备对成功至关重要。但当面临在学习和玩耍之间做出选择时，我们中的很多人都会选择走捷径。
As adults, we know that kindness and civility are what allow communities to function. Yet when we are late or upset, we often act impulsively. We know that we should visit elderly parents or stay in touch with friends who have fallen on hard times. We know we should exercise regularly and make the time to eat healthy. We know sleep and social connection are engines for contentment and well-being. We know these things, but it is so tempting to settle a little deeper into the couch, crack open a fizzy drink, and let Netflix auto-stream another episode of our favourite television
作为成年人，我们知道善良和文明是让社区正常运转的基石。然而，当我们迟到或心烦意乱时，我们往往会冲动行事。我们知道我们应该探望年迈的父母，或者与陷入困境的朋友保持联系。我们知道我们应该定期锻炼，并抽出时间健康饮食。我们知道睡眠和社交联系是满足感和幸福感的动力源泉。我们知道这些道理，但我们又是那么容易在沙发上窝得更舒服一点，打开一罐碳酸饮料，任由奈飞自动播放我们最喜欢的电视剧的下一集。
show. Over the last several decades, the psychologist Elliot Aronson has worked to understand how our minds justify our actions. We explored the origins of Elliot's research in the previous episode. If you missed it, I strongly recommend you start there and listen to it first. We looked at the curious ways cognitive dissonance works and we examined the clash between two of Elliott's mentors,
在过去的几十年里，心理学家埃利奥特·阿伦森一直致力于研究我们的内心是如何为我们的行为辩护的。我们在上一集中探讨了埃利奥特研究的起源。如果你错过了，我强烈建议你从那里开始听起。我们探讨了认知失调奇妙的运作方式，并审视了埃利奥特的两位导师之间的冲突，
the famous psychologist Abraham Maslow and Leon Festinger. This week on Hidden Brain, psychological jujitsu, how to use your mind to get your mind to do what your mind would rather not do. In one of Esaubs' fables, a fox notices a bunch of grapes, high up on a vine. The grapes look delicious and the fox's mouth starts to water. The fox jumps as high as it can, but fails to reach the grapes. The fox tries again, it takes a running start and leaps into the air with all its strength. Again, it misses. Over and over, the fox tries to reach the grapes. Finally, it gives up.
也就是著名的心理学家亚伯拉罕·马斯洛和利昂·费斯廷格。本周的《隐藏的大脑》将探讨心理柔术：如何运用你的心智，让你的心智去做它本不想做的事。在伊索寓言中，一只狐狸注意到高高挂在葡萄藤上的一串串葡萄。葡萄看起来很美味，狐狸开始垂涎欲滴。狐狸拼命往上跳，但够不到葡萄。狐狸又试了一次，它助跑了一段，用尽全身力气跳向空中。结果还是没能够到。狐狸一次又一次地尝试够葡萄。最后，它放弃了。
But before it walks away, it looks contemptuously at the grapes and exclaims. They are sour grapes anyway. anyway. The parable of course is not about foxes, but about us. When we want something but cannot get it, we quiet our disappointment and frustration by denigrating the thing we wanted but cannot have. But let's give the parable a little twist. After leaping and failing to catch the grapes, let's say the fog takes one final mighty leap and manages to reach the grapes.
但在它走开之前，它轻蔑地看着葡萄并大声说道：“反正这些葡萄也是酸的。”这个寓言当然不是关于狐狸的，而是关于我们自己的。当我们想要得到什么却得不到时，我们就会通过贬低我们想要却得不到的东西，来平息我们的失望和沮丧。但让我们给这个寓言来个小转折。在跳跃却没能抓到葡萄之后，假设这只狐狸做了最后一次全力的一跃，并成功够到了葡萄。
What happens now? To the sought after grapes, tastes just like grapes? No, of course not. They taste like the best grapes in the world. As we explored in our previous episode, the story of the Fox and the Sour Graves is a textbook example of the phenomenon known as cognitive dissonance. First conceived by the psychologist Leon Festinger and then developed by Elliot Aronson when he was Leon Festinger student, the theory suggests it is difficult to hold contrasting or dissonant thoughts inside our heads.
现在会发生什么？梦寐以求的葡萄吃起来就像普通的葡萄吗？不，当然不是。它们尝起来就像世界上最好吃的葡萄。正如我们在上一集中探讨的那样，“狐狸与酸葡萄”的故事是被称为认知失调现象的教科书般的例子。该理论最初由心理学家利昂·费斯廷格提出，后来由利昂·费斯廷格的学生埃利奥特·阿伦森进一步发展，该理论表明，我们的脑海中很难同时容纳相互冲突或失调的想法。
In the parable, the fox wants the grapes, but it cannot get them. This dissonance is frustrating. So the fox changes whether it wanted the grapes in the first place. It tells itself the grapes were not really desirable. Elliot says the same thing happens in every domain of our lives. We are all master storytellers, and we are quick to invent stories
在寓言中，狐狸想要葡萄，但它得不到。这种失调让人沮丧。于是狐狸改变了它一开始是否想要葡萄的想法。它告诉自己，这些葡萄其实并不是那么令人向往。埃利奥特说，在我们生活的各个领域都会发生同样的事情。我们都是讲故事的高手，而且我们总是迅速编造故事，
that reduce our cognitive dissonance. An early experiment that Elliot helped to set up illustrates this idea. It's an experiment on cheating. The way I visualize it is, and I'd like you and your listeners to visualize it this way, think of a pyramid and think of the apex, the very tippy top of that pyramid as being a person's attitude on a particular issue. Let's say on cheating. Now, suppose you're a student and you want to go to medical school and you're in a biology class in your senior year
来减少我们的认知失调。埃利奥特协助建立的一个早期实验说明了这个观点。这是一个关于作弊的实验。我将其可视化的方式是——我也希望你和你的听众这样可视化——想象一座金字塔，并把金字塔的顶端、最尖端想象成一个人对特定问题的态度。比如说，对作弊的态度。现在，假设你是一名学生，你想去医学院，你在大四时上了一门生物课，
and you know it's an important class and how well you do in this class is going to have a major impact on whether or not you can get admitted to a good medical school. You go in for the final exam, you think you know the stuff well enough and you look at the questions and you pulled a blank, you panic, you don't know a single thing, it's as if you never took the class and you break into a cults what you don't know what to do. And then you look around and you see that you happen to be sitting right behind the smartest person in the class who also has the largest and most easily readable handwriting. So, so you can, you can decide just by craning my neck a little, I can read what's on her paper, copy
你知道这是一门重要的课，你在该课上表现如何，将对你是否能被一所好的医学院录取产生重大影响。你去参加期末考试，你觉得你对材料的掌握程度足够好，但当你看着试题时，你的脑子却一片空白，你惊慌失措，你连一个字都想不起来，就像你从来没上过这门课一样，你急得冷汗直流，不知道该怎么办。然后你环顾四周，发现自己恰好坐在班上最聪明的人后面，而且那个人拥有最大、最容易辨认的字迹。所以，所以你可以，你只需要稍微伸长脖子，就能看清她试卷上的内容，抄下来，
it, and do well on the course and get into medical school, but it's an immoral thing to do. Now, imagine there are two people in exactly the same position, and they're both sitting on the apex of that pyramid and have almost identical attitudes toward cheating. It's not a good thing to do, but it's not the worst thing in the world, and a lot of people do it, and it's kind of built into the system. It's not so bad. It's immoral, but there are much worse things in the world. And one of them decides to cheat, and one of them decides not to cheat. Now imagine, as soon as they make that decision, they're sliding down opposite sides of that pyramid.
然后在这门课上取得好成绩并进入医学院，但这是一件不道德的事。现在，想象有两个处于完全相同位置的人，他们都坐在金字塔的顶端，对作弊有着几乎相同的态度。这不是一件好事，但也不是世上最坏的事，很多人都这样做，而且它有点像是系统内置的一部分。没那么糟糕。它是不道德的，但世上有坏得多得多的事。其中一个人决定作弊，另一个人决定不作弊。现在想象一下，一旦他们做出决定，他们就在金字塔的两侧向下滑落。
Eliot calls the start experiment the pyramid of choice. Picture a triangle in your mind. Two people are at the apex about to make a decision on whether to cheat. They make different decisions and start to slide down opposite sides of the triangle. When they reach the bottom, they are far apart. The base of the triangle has two ends, and these ends represent diametrically different views about cheating. On the left hand side is, it's not important, it's a minor thing, it's, here everybody
埃利奥特将最初的实验称为“选择金字塔”。在脑海中想象一个三角形。两个人都在顶端，即将对是否作弊做出决定。他们做出了不同的决定，并开始沿着三角形的两侧向下滑落。当他们到达底部时，他们已经相距甚远。三角形的底边有两个端点，这两个端点代表了对作弊截然不同的看法。左边是：这不重要，这是一件小事，这，在这里每个人
does it, it's a victimless crime, nobody is harmed by my cheating. And on the extreme right hand side of that base is, cheating is a terrible thing to do. You're depriving other people of an opportunity to do as well as you're doing. You're taking somebody else's place in medical school. It's not a victimless crime. It's terrible. And if everybody always did it, it would be a terrible society. And anyone who's caught cheating should be immediately kicked
都这样做，这是一个没有受害者的犯罪，没有人因为我的作弊而受到伤害。而那个底边的最右端则是：作弊是一件极其糟糕的事。你在剥夺其他人表现得和你一样好的机会。你在医学院里占用了别人的名额。这不是一件没有受害者的犯罪。这太糟糕了。如果每个人都一直这样做，那将是一个糟糕透顶的社会。任何被抓到作弊的人都应该被立即开除
out of school. Those are the two extreme positions. And according to distance theory, if you decide to cheat, your cognition that you are a moral ethical person is dissonant with your cognition that you committed an immoral unethical act. And therefore, you will slide down that left hand side of the pyramid and end up at the bottom saying, cheating is nothing, everybody does it. If you decide not to cheat, you will slide down the other side of the pyramid because you experienced cognitive dissonance.
出学校。这就是那两个极端的立场。根据失调理论，如果你决定作弊，你“自己是一个道德正直的人”这一认知，与你“自己做出了一项不道德、不正直的行为”这一认知是失调的。因此，你将顺着金字塔的左侧滑落，最终在底部落脚，并说：作弊没什么大不了的，大家都这么做。如果你决定不作弊，你就会顺着金字塔的另一侧滑落，因为你体验到了认知失调。
I had a chance to go to a great medical school. All I had to do was look over that girl's shoulder at her exam and I flubbed that opportunity. Therefore, I have to believe that if I had taken that opportunity, I would have committed a terrible sin, cheating as a terrible thing. I'm glad I didn't do it. Either way, you see, whether you decide to cheat or not to cheat, you experience cognitive dissonance. And so you get to change attitudes dramatically in either one direction or the other, depending upon that one decision that a person makes. And in some ways, both those people
我有机会去一所伟大的医学院。我所需要做的只是看一眼那个女孩肩膀上的试卷，而我却把这个机会搞砸了。因此，我必须相信，如果我当时抓住了那个机会，我就会犯下滔天大罪，作弊是一件极其糟糕的事。我很高兴我没有那样做。无论哪种方式，你看，无论你决定作弊还是不作弊，你都会体验到认知失调。因此，根据一个人做出的那一个决定，你可以朝一个方向或另一个方向大幅度地改变态度。在某种程度上，这两个
who are sliding down these opposite ends of the pyramid, unconsciously, what they're really doing is trying to get to a place where they can sleep while at night. So one person is saying, yes, I cheated on the exam and maybe that wasn't the best thing to do, but on the other hand, I'm gonna become an off become an ophthalmologist one day and I'm going to save people's eyes and I'll be able to help them see.
顺着金字塔相反两端向下滑落的人，在无意识中，他们真正做的其实是试图到达一个能让他们晚上安稳睡觉的地方。所以一个人会说：是的，我在考试中作弊了，也许那不是最好的做法，但从另一方面来说，我有一天会成为一名眼科医生，我要拯救人们的眼睛，我能帮助他们重见光明。
I'm going to do all of this good in the world and the fact that I had to do a little bit of bad to do all this good is totally worthwhile. And the other person basically says, I'm a moral person because I didn't cheat. And yes, it does mean that I couldn't go to medical school but isn't'm a moral person because I didn't cheat. And yes, it does mean that I couldn't go to medical school, but isn't being a moral person good for me and good for my soul and ultimately good for society. And both people are telling themselves stories that allow them to sleep well at night. Exactly right. Exactly right. Now we have this person who's able to think going through this elaborate thing, which is making him feel good about the action he's just taken.
我要在世界上做好事，为了做好这些好事而不得不做一点坏事，这是完全值得的。另一个人基本上会说：我是一个道德高尚的人，因为我没有作弊。是的，这确实意味着我没能去医学院，但难道……我是一个道德高尚的人，因为我没有作弊。是的，这确实意味着我没能去医学院，但作为一个道德高尚的人，这对我有好处，对我的灵魂有好处，最终对社会也有好处。这两个人都在告诉自己一些故事，让他们晚上能睡个安稳觉。完全正确。完全正确。现在我们有这样一个人，他能够思考并经历这件复杂的事情，这让他对刚刚做出的行为感觉良好。
So, do you ever wonder, Elliot, given the fact that our ability to study our own minds is something that we are doing with our minds, and our minds as we are seeing our sort of these flawed machines. It's hard to sort of know what the correct thing is to think in the situation, in the cheating experiment, regardless of which choice you make, you're going to experience cognitive dissonance,
所以，埃利奥特，你有没有想过，鉴于我们研究自己大脑的能力本身就是用我们的大脑在做的事情，而且正如我们所看到的，我们的大脑就像是有缺陷的机器。在这个情境中，很难知道正确的想法是什么。在作弊实验中，无论你做出什么选择，你都会体验到认知失调，
and you're going to rationalize the decision you've made, is it actually absurd to ask what the right answer is, because regardless of what you do, your mind is going to come up with a story that tells you what's the right thing to do? When it comes to making a moral decision, which has, especially one that has consequences for other people, we really have to be very careful. If you're the leader, especially the leader of a country, you have to surround yourself with people who might not always agree with you so that they
并且你会为你做出的决定进行合理化解释。那么，询问什么是正确的答案其实是不是很荒谬？因为无论你做什么，你的大脑都会想出一个故事来告诉你什么是正确的事？当涉及做出道德决策时，尤其是对其他人会产生后果的决策时，我们真的必须非常小心。如果你是领导者，特别是一个国家的领导者，你必须让自己周围环绕着那些可能并不总是同意你观点的人，以便他们
can point out the flaws in your thinking. Exactly what according to Doris Kern's good one in her wonderful book about Abraham Lincoln, how he surrounded himself with three people who ran against him for the presidency of the United States at that time. They were all in his cabinet and he listened to them. I think that's the thing to do. If you surround yourself with yes men, you're apt in your need to reduce dissonance, you're apt in your need to reduce dissonance, you're apt to go ahead and make some terrible mistakes because everybody around will agree with you. When it's an important decision that involves other people, you really
能够指出你思维中的缺陷。正如多丽丝·库恩斯·古德温在她那本关于亚伯拉罕·林肯的精彩著作中所说的那样，林肯正是这样做的：他让当时在总统竞选中与他竞选的三个人加入自己的内阁，并倾听他们的意见。我认为这才是应该做的。如果你身边都是唯唯诺诺的人，为了减少失调的需求，为了减少失调的需求，你很有可能会继续犯下一些可怕的错误，因为你周围的每个人都会同意你的观点。当这是一个涉及其他人的重要决定时，你真的
have to scrutinize yourself carefully and ask yourself, is this something I truly believe in? Or am I simply justifying something that I've done in the past or justifying my own needs for the future? And am I fooling myself to make myself feel a little bit better? These are the important questions we need to ask ourselves when the decision is an important one. If it's a trivial one that only involves myself, cognitive dissonance reduction can be a very useful tool that helps me sleep well at night and help me feel good about the decisions that I've made. It would do no good to worry about that decision afterward and doesn't help anybody.
必须仔细审视自己，并问自己：这是我真正信仰的吗？还是我只是在为我过去做过的事进行辩护，或者在为我未来的需求进行辩护？我是不是在自我欺骗，好让自己的感觉稍微好一点？当这是一个重大的决定时，这些都是我们需要问自己的重要问题。如果这是一个只涉及我自己的微不足道的小决定，减少认知失调可以是一个非常有用的工具，它能帮助我晚上睡个好觉，并让我对自己做出的决定感觉良好。事后去纠结那个决定没有任何好处，也帮不到任何人。
Cognitive dissonance can seem like a bad thing, and it can in fact have serious consequences. But it is really just a tool in the brain that allows us to resolve seemingly unresolved elitious. When we come back, Elliott shares how cognitive dissonance can be deployed to accomplish important goals. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Psychologist Elliot Aronson has spent decades thinking about cognitive dissonance. He has explored how our minds come up with justifications for our actions and when those justifications can be harmful and when they can have solitary effects. An early example of the power of cognitive dissonance came in Eliot's own life.
认知失调看起来可能是一件坏事，它事实上也可能带来严重的后果。但它其实只是大脑中的一个工具，让我们能够解决看似无法解决的矛盾。稍后回来，埃利奥特将分享如何运用认知失调来实现重要的目标。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。心理学家埃利奥特·阿伦森花了几十年时间思考认知失调。他探讨了我们的思维如何为我们的行动寻找理由，这些理由在什么时候会产生有害影响，以及它们在什么时候会产生积极效果。认知失调力量的一个早期例子出现在埃利奥特自己的生活中。
Early in his career, he landed a plum job at Harvard University. I was there for two years, and just starting my third year, when I was offered a wonderful position at the University of Minnesota. And it was just a dream job. But in order to go there, I had to leave Harvard, which was, in most most respects a very nice place to be. Elliot debated long and hard about whether to make the move.
在他职业生涯的早期，他在哈佛大学获得了一份优厚的工作。我在那里待了两年，刚开始第三年的时候，明尼苏达大学向我提供了一个绝佳的职位。那简直是一份梦想中的工作。但为了去那里，我不得不离开哈佛，从大多数方面来看，那都是一个非常美好的地方。埃利奥特就究竟要不要搬走进行了长时间而艰难的辩论。
I finally decided to take that job. And when I got to Minnesota, I realized, for the first time, Harvard is a place which is very stratified, not a lot of intermingling between the assistant professors and the folk professors. When I got to Minnesota, the whole atmosphere was very, very different. Everybody becomes buddies with everybody else, and the status of the person makes very little difference. There was a much more democratic atmosphere that I noticed. But of course, as I'm noticing this, I'm aware of the fact that the things I'm doing right now
我最终决定接受那份工作。当我到达明尼苏达时，我第一次意识到，哈佛是一个等级森严的地方，助理教授和正教授之间没有太多密切交往。当我到达明尼苏达时，整个氛围非常非常不同。每个人都和彼此成了好朋友，个人的身份地位几乎没有什么影响。我注意到这里有一种更加民主的氛围。当然，当我注意到这一点时，我也意识到我正在做的事情
are convincing myself that the University of Minnesota is a great place to be, and maybe I was motivated, highly motivated to see those advantages. And of course, if you had stayed at Harvard, it's sort of moving to Minnesota. Presumably, your mind would have come up with rationalizations about why that was the right decision. I would assume so. And boy, you know, it's a useful mechanism And boy, you know, it's a useful mechanism once you're in it, as long as it doesn't do you any harm, because it helps you sleep at night. After Reliet moved to Minnesota,
其实是在说服自己明尼苏达大学是个好地方，也许我受到了强烈的动机去看到那些优势。当然，如果你留在哈佛，这有点像搬到明尼苏达。可以推测，你的大脑也会想出一套合理化的解释，说明为什么那是正确的决定。我想是的。天哪，你知道的，这是一个有用的机制。天哪，你知道的，只要它不给你带来任何伤害，它就是一个有用的机制，因为它能帮你安稳入睡。埃利奥特搬到明尼苏达后，
he went house hunting with his wife. As would be house hunters everywhere often discover, the experience provided ample opportunities for cognitive dissonance. We didn't have much money, but we wanted to buy a house, and there were only two houses that we could afford that we really liked, and they couldn't have been more different. One was near campus, it was a beautiful little Victorian, it was also near an industrial area where Pillsbury was grinding up grain and things like that.
他和妻子一起去物色房子。正如到处看房的人经常发现的那样，这段经历为认知失调提供了充足的机会。我们当时没有多少钱，但我们想买一套房子，我们能买得起并且真正喜欢的房子只有两套，而且它们简直大相径庭。一套靠近校园，是一栋漂亮的小维多利亚式住宅，它也靠近一个工业区，那里有品食乐公司在磨碎谷物之类的东西。
And it didn't have much of a yard. But boy, I really wanted that house because it was close to campus and my image was to have my graduate students come over at four or five o'clock in the afternoon and we could sit around and drink scotch or coffee and talk about research ideas in my living room. That to me was the ideal of being a professor. The other house was out in the suburbs, a 20 minute drive from campus. It was a plenty the suburbs, a 20-minute drive from campus.
而且它的院子很小。但是天哪，我真的很想要那栋房子，因为它离校园很近，我的设想是让我的研究生们在下午四五点钟过来，我们可以坐在客厅里喝着苏格兰威士忌或咖啡，讨论研究想法。对我来说，那就是当教授的理想状态。另一栋房子在郊区，开车离校园20分钟。那是一处位于郊区的房子，开车离校园20分钟。
It was a plenty of room, plenty of space. It wasn't the houses were not cheek-to-jowl, but they were all separated. Beautiful big backyard, but a very common looking house, nothing good about it, particularly, but a great place for the kids. We had four young kids between the ages of six months old and seven years old and we needed space for the kids. And we were near a lake, Lake Oassol. So my wife and I couldn't decide which of the two houses to get, we went back and forth several times, and finally we decided on the house in the suburbs for the sake of the children. It wasn't what Elliott had wanted, but soon enough he began to rationalize the decision.
那里有充足的房间，充足的空间。房子并不是紧挨着彼此的，而是互相分开的。有一个漂亮的大后院，但房子看起来很普通，没有什么特别好的地方，不过对孩子们来说是个好地方。我们有四个年幼的孩子，年龄在六个月到七岁之间，我们需要给孩子们活动的空间。而且我们离奥索尔湖很近。所以我和妻子无法决定究竟买这两栋房子中的哪一套，我们反复斟酌了好几次，最后为了孩子们的缘故，我们决定买郊区的那栋房子。这并不是埃利奥特想要的，但很快他就开始为这个决定进行合理化解释。
He had to give up that image of himself at the center of a circle of graduate students in his Victorian living room, but wasn't this better for the kids, and wasn't that more important? In time, though, the story Elliot told himself about the democratic egalitarian nature of his Minnesota colleagues, and the extra space provided by his suburban home ran into a large obstacle. Even though he was coming to the Midwest from New England, where the winters are hard, it was difficult not to notice
他不得不放弃自己坐在维多利亚式客厅里、被研究生环绕的形象，但这难道对孩子们更好吗？难道这不更重要吗？不过随着时间推移，埃利奥特对自己讲述的关于明尼苏达同事具有民主平等本质的故事，以及郊区住宅提供的额外空间，遇到了一个巨大的障碍。尽管他是从冬天严寒的新英格兰来到中西部的，但他依然很难不注意到
the approach of the fearsome Minnesota winter. Soon enough, Eliot's mind came up with a way to grapple with this challenge too. So what happened was, we bought the house in early November in early December, about three or four weeks after we bought the house. I saw an ad in a newspaper for a used canoe, and I went out and bought it. We had this old station wagon with a luggage rack on top. I tied the canoe to the top of the station wagon
可怕的明尼苏达冬天的逼近。很快，埃利奥特的脑海里就想出了一种应对这个挑战的方法。所以发生的事情是，我们在11月初、12月初买下了房子，买下房子大约三四周后。我在报纸上看到了一则关于二手独木舟的广告，然后我跑出去把它买了下来。我们有一辆顶上有行李架的老旧旅行车。我把独木舟绑在旅行车顶上，
and drove back to this house in the suburbs, drove into the driveway. My wife sees me coming, looks out the kitchen window, sees the canoe on top of the car, and bursts into laughter. I get in the house, I said, what's so funny? She points to the canoe and she says, ask Leon, meaning Leon festering it, he could tell you why I find it so funny. And of course, as soon as she said that, it dawned on me that I bought that canoe in the middle of winter. Now, winters in Minneapolis last for a very long time.
开车回到了郊区的这栋房子，把车开进了车道。我妻子看到我回来，从厨房窗户往外看，看到车顶上的独木舟，然后爆发出大笑。我走进屋里，说：“有什么好笑的？”她指着独木舟说：“去问问利昂”——意思是利昂·费斯廷格——“他能告诉你为什么我觉得这这么好笑。”当然，她一这么说，我便恍然大悟，我竟然在大冬天买了一艘独木舟。现在，明尼阿波利斯的冬天持续时间非常长。
In the winter time, the lakes have frozen over, frozen so solid that people often drive their cars across the lakes as a short cut. The unofficial first day of spring in Minneapolis is the first time a car falls through the ice, okay? And that wouldn't occur. I wouldn't be able to use that canoe on the lake until the middle of May sometime. So why did I buy the canoe in December when I couldn't use it till May? Well, maybe there was a bargain price or something. No, that's bulls**t. The reason I bought it was because I was unhappy with the decision and I wanted to reduce
在冬天，湖面结了冰，冻得如此结实，以至于人们经常把车开过湖面来当做捷径。明尼阿波利斯非官方的春天第一天，就是第一辆车掉进冰窟窿的那一天，好吧？而这不会发生。直到五月中旬左右，我才能在湖上使用那艘独木舟。那么为什么我会在十二月买一艘直到五月才能使用的独木舟呢？嗯，也许是因为价格便宜或者别的什么。不，这纯属放屁。我买它的原因是因为我对那个决定感到不满意，我想减少
this and then say, aha, but this house we bought in the suburbs is close to a lake. I'm going to go out there with my kids and teach them how to canoe. It's going to be wonderful. We're going to have a great time. It's a beautiful example of cognitive dissonance because at the time I was doing it, I was unaware of why I was doing it. My wife pointing it out to me, I mean, I'm steeped in cognitive dissonance. And yet it's an unconscious process. I wasn't aware of it. As soon as my wife pointed it out, I realized I was doing it. And it was a reasonable thing to do.
这种感觉，然后告诉自己：“啊哈，但是我们买在郊区这栋房子靠近一个湖。我要带着我的孩子们去那里，教他们怎么划独木舟。那一定会很棒。我们会玩得很开心。”这是一个认知失调的绝佳例子，因为我在做这件事的时候，我并没有意识到自己为什么要这么做。经我妻子一指出，我的意思是，我整个人都浸泡在认知失调中。然而这是一个无意识的过程。我并没有意识到。一旦我妻子指出来，我才意识到我一直在这样做。而且这是一件合理的事情。
You know, one might say, yeah, but for the next six months that canoe is just gonna be taking up space in the garage. No, wrong. It's gonna be helping me sleep at night because I can be thinking about, yeah, but I have this canoe and look at all the good things I can do with it, even though it's going to take me a few months before I can start doing that. It has a lot of value.
你知道，可能会有人说：“是的，但在接下来的六个月里，那艘独木舟只会占满车库的空间。”不，大错特错。它能帮我晚上睡个好觉，因为我可以想着：“对，但我有这艘独木舟，看看我能用它做多少好事，尽管我还要过几个月才能开始做。”它有着巨大的价值。
Yeah, so the story is a charming story and it's a funny story, but you can also see when the stakes are much bigger if I'm a politician for example And I launch my country into war and the war is not going well and things are backfiring on me I now can either tell myself, you know, I made a dreadful mistake and as a result of the mistake that I've made You know other human beings have died and their their families that going to grow up without a father or a brother or a mother or a friend. And so in order to not feel that, in order to sleep well at night, I say, all right, maybe what I should do is actually send even more troops there so we can finish up this war and come back victorious and everyone will say that I did the right thing.
对，所以这个故事是个迷人的故事，也是个有趣的故事，但你也可以看到，当赌注大得多时，比如如果我是一个政治家，我把我的国家拖入战争，而战争进展不顺，事情对我产生了反作用，我现在要么告诉自己：“你知道，我犯了一个可怕的错误，作为我犯下这个错误的结果，你知道，其他人死去了，他们的家人将在没有父亲、兄弟、母亲或朋友的陪伴下长大。”因此，为了不去感受这一点，为了晚上能睡个好觉，我说：“好吧，也许我应该做的是向那里派遣更多的军队，这样我们就能结束这场战争并带着胜利归来，每个人都会说我做对了。”
I'm really extrapolating here several orders of magnitude. I recognize I'm really extrapolating here several orders of magnitude. I recognize I'm doing that, but I think the same mechanisms that happened with you in Minnesota and the canoe happen all the time at much, much bigger scales. Exactly right. And that's pretty much how I think George W. Bush went through when he invaded Iraq because he thought that Saddam Hussein had weapons of mass destruction. Saddam Hussein has gone to elaborate lengths, spending ormissums, taking great risks to build and keep weapons of mass destruction.
我在这里真的外推了好几个数量级。我承认我在这里确实外推了好几个数量级。我承认我在这么做，但我认为，你在明尼苏达和独木舟身上发生的那些相同的机制，一直在以更大得多的规模不断发生。完全正确。这差不多也就是乔治·W·布什在入侵伊拉克时经历的心路历程，因为他认为萨达姆·侯赛因拥有大规模杀伤性武器。萨达姆·侯赛因曾费尽心机、耗费巨资、冒着巨大风险去制造和保留大规模杀伤性武器。
And that was the whole justification for that invasion. As you may remember, it came on the heels of September 11th, but Saddam Hussein had nothing to do with September 11th, and he didn't have weapons of mass destruction, and they couldn't find them, and when they couldn't find them, George W. Bush is saying, oh, we'll find them. They're someplace. We do know that Saddam Hussein had the intent and the capabilities to cause great harm. We know he was a danger. But he never did find them. And when the war wasn't
而这就是那次入侵的全部理由。你可能还记得，它紧随9·11事件之后发生，但萨达姆·侯赛因与9·11事件毫无关系，他也没有大规模杀伤性武器，而且他们找不到武器。当他们找不到时，乔治·W·布什却在说：“哦，我们会找到的。它们在某个地方。”我们确实知道萨达姆·侯赛因有造成巨大伤害的意图和能力。我们知道他是个危险人物。但他从来没有找到武器。当战争没有像他预期那样
winding down as quickly as he expected, he put more troops in. And more troops in. He put more troops in and more troops in did a lot of destruction both in terms of people and places You know we first got in there started looking around and didn't find anything as you get that kind of sinking feeling that Oh, and then yeah, I felt terrible about it and On the other hand Those reports did point out that Saddam Hussein was very dangerous, that he had the capacity to make weapons. And I'm convinced that if he were in power today, the world would be at a lot worse off.
迅速结束时，他投入了更多的军队。又投入了更多的军队。他投入了更多的军队，更多的军队在人员和地点方面造成了巨大的破坏。你知道，当我们刚到那里开始四处搜寻却一无所获时，你会有一种那种沉重下坠的感觉：“哦……”然后，是的，我对此感到糟糕透顶。另一方面，那些报告确实指出萨达姆·侯赛因非常危险，他有制造武器的能力。我坚信，如果他今天仍然掌权，这个世界将会糟糕得多。
And I think that's the kind of way that the cognitive dissonance works on a political level, on an international level, that can be and has been, in my opinion, disastrous. Why is it that we feel so impelled to self-justify our actions, Elliot, when we're choosing to do something where that is to move from Harvard to Minnesota or to marry one person or divorce someone else? Why is it that we feel this powerful urge to justify our own actions? Well, I think we're hardwired to believe that we are good, smart, competent moral people. Most people think they're better than average as in intelligence, better than average, average as intelligence, better than average,
我认为这就是认知失调在政治层面、国际层面上运作的方式，在我看来，这可能而且已经造成了灾难性的后果。埃利奥特，为什么当我们选择做某件事时——无论是从哈佛搬到明尼苏达，还是与某人结婚或离婚——我们总是感到如此迫切地需要为自己的行为进行自我辩护呢？为什么我们会有这种强大的冲动去为主张自己的行为寻找理由呢？嗯，我认为我们的大脑天生就倾向于相信自己是善良、聪明、能干、有道德的人。大多数人都认为自己高于平均水平，比如智力高于平均水平、作为司机……
as a driver, better than average, and most things, so that whenever they do something that seems stupid, incompetent, or immoral, it creates dissonance with that self-concept that almost all of us have, and therefore we need to reduce it. Now not all not all people have a high self-concept but the overwhelming majority of people do and that's what motivates us. As he saw how cognitive dissonance worked in his own life and in public life, Eliot started to ask himself a provocative question.
驾驶水平高于平均水平，以及在大多数事情上都高于平均水平，因此每当他们做出看起来愚蠢、无能或不道德的事情时，它就会与我们几乎所有人都有的这种自我概念产生失调，因此我们需要减少这种失调。现在，并非所有人都有很高的自我概念，但绝大多数人都有，这就是我们的动力所在。随着埃利奥特看到认知失调在自己的生活和公众生活中是如何运作的，他开始问自己一个挑衅性的问题。
It was clear cognitive dissonance was routinely deployed by individuals to make themselves feel better about their decisions. And it was clear that cognitive dissonance could prompt leaders and countries to double down on disastrous policies. But cognitive dissonance in itself was neither good nor bad. So could you use it to do good? That's when we come back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Psychologist Elliot Aronson studies how we justify our own actions. By the 1980s, Elliot had moved to the University of California Santa Cruz.
很显然，个人经常会运用认知失调来让自己对自己的决定感觉更好。而且很显然，认知失调会促使领导者和国家在灾难性的政策上越走越远。但认知失调本身无所谓好坏。那么，你能用它来做好事吗？稍后我们再来探讨。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。心理学家埃利奥特·阿伦森研究我们如何为自己的行为辩护。到了20世纪80年代，埃利奥特已经搬到了加州大学圣克鲁斯分校。
The AIDS epidemic was spreading and the campus student health center was trying to promote sexual health. The problem was, nothing was working. My students and I did some survey research of college students and we found that they didn't like to use condoms because condoms were unromantic. There's nothing really sexy about a condom and they didn't like using them and they're inconvenient. They were convincing themselves that it was okay that they were being careful enough. And student health centers were trying all kinds of lectures and education and none of it was having much of an impact.
艾滋病疫情正在蔓延，校园里的学生健康中心正试图推广性健康。问题是，什么方法都不管用。我和我的学生对大学生做了一些调查研究，我们发现他们不喜欢使用安全套，因为安全套不够浪漫。安全套其实没什么性感可言，他们不喜欢使用，而且很不方便。他们一直在说服自己，认为这样没问题，他们已经足够小心了。而学生健康中心尝试了各种讲座和教育，但都没有产生多大影响。
So they asked me on my campus if there was anything I could do. Elliott wondered if there was a way to make condoms more attractive. He designed a PSA, a public service announcement that talked up the benefits of condoms. But it didn't work or rather it worked for a little while. Right after seeing the video, large number of students began using condoms, but only for a few weeks and after a few weeks they stopped doing it. So then I thought, well, we need to find a way to use cognitive dissonance, because cognitive dissonance, reduction of dissonance, usually produces long-term effects, because the people are convincing themselves to use condoms. They're not using them because you told them to use them, or because you showed them a movie that was trying to convince them to
于是他们问我，在我的校园里有没有什么办法。埃利奥特想知道是否有办法让安全套更具吸引力。他设计了一则公益广告（PSA），宣传使用安全套的好处。但这并没有起作用，或者说它只起了一小会儿作用。看完视频后，大量学生开始使用安全套，但只持续了几周，几周后他们就停用了。于是我想，好吧，我们需要找到一种方法来利用认知失调，因为认知失调、对失调的减少通常会产生长期效果，因为人们是在说服自己使用安全套。他们使用不是因为你告诉他们要用，或者因为你给他们看了一部试图说服他们使用安全套的电影，而是因为他们自己决定使用安全套。那么，如何做到这一点呢？这并不是一件容易建立的事。于是我开始思考，你可以通过让一个人去尝试说服其他人这样做来实现这一点，让他们挺身而出倡导使用安全套。之所以这可能行得通，是因为所有的学生都认为使用安全套对别人来说是一件好事，但他们自己却没有使用。如果他们能够说服别人使用，就等于暗示他们自己也在使用，我们就会把他们置于一个失调的情境中，他们就能说服自己，使用安全套确实是他们应该做的事，
use condoms, it's that they themselves decided to use condoms. Now, how do you do that? It's not an easy thing to set up. So then I began to think you do it by getting a person to try to convince other people to do it, to go out on a limb advocating the use of condoms. And the reason that that might work is that all of the students believed that using condoms was a good thing for other people, but they themselves weren't using it. If they could convince others to use it, by implying that they themselves were using it, we would put them in a dissonance situation, they could convince themselves that the use of condoms was really something they should be doing
因为他们已经暗示过自己在这么做了。我们就是这么做的。我们让大学生制作了一段录像带，我们在制作上给予了协助。他们自己编写内容，谈论艾滋病的危害，以及他们认为使用安全套是预防艾滋病、避免感染艾滋病的最佳方式。我们告诉他们，我们制作的这些录像带将在高中生的性教育课程中作为他们课程的一部分播放。
because they already implied that they were doing it. And that's what we did. We got college students to make a videotape, which we helped them make. They composed it themselves, talking about the dangers of AIDS and the fact that they believe that using condoms was the best way to prevent getting AIDS, to keep from getting AIDS. And we told them that these video types that we were making, they were gonna be played to high school students as part of their sex education course.
然后我们追踪了他们使用安全套的情况。我们发现，在长达六个月后，那些表示自己在使用安全套的人数大幅增加，从我们校园里的大约18%飙升至大约68%，在六个月后这是一个巨大的飞跃。在另一项类似的研究中，埃利奥特和加州大学圣克鲁斯分校的学生呼吁大家通过洗短一点的澡来保护环境并缓解加州著名的干旱。圣克鲁斯分校是一个非常有趣的校园。学生们都相信全球变暖的重要性。
And then we tracked their use of condoms. And we found that the number of people who said they were using condoms as much as six months later had gone up enormously from about 18% which it was on our campus to about 68% which was a huge leap six months later. In a similar study, Elliott and Carrot students at UC Santa Cruz to protect the environment and ease California's famous droughts by taking shorter showers. Santa Cruz is a very interesting campus. The students all believe in the importance of global warming.
他们都相信拯救红杉树的重要性。他们都相信拯救红杉树的重要性。他们都相信所有的环保议题。但当你让他们因为我们面临的长期水资源短缺而洗短一点的澡时，他们却不照做。因为洗个短澡不仅仅是洗干净身体那么简单。你可以洗一个三分钟的澡，也能洗得很干净。但这是一种奢华的体验，人们享受在洗澡时享受这种奢侈。于是我们决定采用我们在安全套实验中使用的相同范式，我称之为“伪善范式”。这就是让人意识到他们的行为是伪善的，而改变这一状况的唯一方法，就是让他们开始
They all believe in saving the Redwood trees. They all believe in saving the Redwood trees. They all believe in all the environmental issues. But when you ask them to take short showers because of the perennial water shortage we have, they don't do it. Because taking a short shower is more than just getting clean. You can take a three minute shower and be pretty clean. But it's a luxurious experience and people enjoy luxurious eating in the shower. So then we decided to use the same paradigm we used in the condom experiments, which I call the hypocrisy paradigm. It's making people aware of the fact that they're behaving hypocritically, and the only way to change that is for them to start
采取与他们的公开声明相一致的行为。好的，在洗澡的研究中，我甚至比安全套研究更喜欢这项研究，因为我们面对的不是人们告诉我们他们在做什么，我们面对的是实际的行为。所以我们做的是，我们在活动中心张贴了一张巨幅海报，上面写着：“节约用水，洗短澡，如果我能做到，你也能。”然后他们的名字用醒目的大字印刷在该标语下方。我们让人们在张贴于活动中心、供公众浏览的那个标语上签上自己的名字，几乎所有我们要求这么做的人都愿意这样做。然后我们安排了一个人在浴室里拿着防水秒表，
behaving in a way that's in line with their public statements. Okay, so in the shower study, I like that study even better than the condom study because we're not dealing with people telling us what they're doing. We're dealing with actual behavior. So what we did was, there's a big poster that we're putting up in the field house that said, conserve water, take short showers, if I can do it, so can you. And then their name is printed in big block letters underneath that sign. And we got people to put their name on that sign that was posted in the field house in public view and almost everybody that we asked to do that were willing to do it. And then we had somebody stationed in the shower room with a waterproof stop watch And as soon as the person got under the shower
只要那个人走进淋浴间并打开水龙头，他们就开始按秒表。而只要他们关掉水龙头，他们就停下秒表。我们得到的结果是不可思议的。研究人员发现，当人们公开承诺洗短澡时，他们洗澡的时间要短得多。原因很简单。如果我刚刚公开表示支持节水，然后在几分钟后洗澡时却没有节水，
and turned it on, they started a stopwatch. And as soon as they stopped, they stopped the stopwatch. And the results we got were incredible. The researchers found that people took much shorter showers when they had made a public commitment to taking short showers. The reason was simple. If I had just publicly declared my support for water conservation, and then didn't conserve water when I was in the shower
这会让我有什么感觉？我会觉得自己像个伪善者。我刚刚签署了那个请愿书。它就挂在那里，所有人都能看到。它会一直挂在那儿。我们张贴了好几张这样的海报。它会一直挂在那儿，我们张贴了好几张。它会一直挂在那儿，直到永远。我必须开始洗短澡。
a few minutes later, how would that make me feel? I would feel like a hypocrite. I just signed that petition. It's up there for everybody to see. It will be up there. There were several of these that we put up. It will be up there, there were several of these that we put up. It will be up there forever. I have to start taking short showers.
这是我能让自己不觉得像个伪善者的唯一方法。最近，埃利奥特利用他的研究来帮助推动2012年总统大选的投票率。他担心当时有人在压制黑人选票。一位与巴拉克·奥巴马总统竞选团队有联系的朋友问埃利奥特是否有任何解决这个问题的想法。不管有没有用，埃利奥特坚持认为他的目的不是出于党派之争。他纯粹是为了鼓励人们去投票。我提出了以下计划。你去黑人教堂，在周日让牧师发表一次简短的布道，他在布道中谈到投票以及投票的重要性，并
That the only way I can keep from feeling like a hypocrite. More recently, Eliot used his research to help get out the vote during the 2012 presidential election. He was concerned that there were efforts underway to suppress the Black vote. A friend connected with President Barack Obama's campaign asked Elliott if he had any ideas to address the issue. For what it's worth, Elliott insists his aim was not partisan. It was merely to encourage people to vote. I came up with a following plan. You go to black churches and on a Sunday you get the minister to deliver a short sermon in which he talks about voting and the importance of voting and in
实际上对他的会众说：“你们的很多兄弟姐妹为了让你们获得投票权而献出了生命。因此，你们在每一次选举中都去投票是非常重要的，包括即将到来的这一次，不要让任何人阻止你们投票。我希望你们现在都同意去投票。所有同意投票的人请举手。”会众中的每个人在照做时都举起了手。然后他说：“好的，现在，就在此时此刻，我希望你们给三个朋友或亲戚打电话，并把刚才我对你们说的话一字不落地告诉他们，
effect says to his congregation, a great many of your brothers and sisters died in order to get you the vote. So, it's important that you vote in every election including the upcoming one and don't let them discourage you from voting. And I want you to all agree now to vote. And all of those who agreed to vote raise your hand. And everybody in the congregation, when they did it, raised their hand. Then he said, OK, now, right now, I want you to call three of your friends or relatives and Tell them exactly what I told you right now
把我刚才跟你们讲的关于你们的兄弟姐妹的话告诉他们，我希望你们对他们说——确保你们使用这些确切的词语：‘去投票吧，如果我能做到，你也能。’”他们照做了。他们说：“如果我能做到，你也能”，这与洗浴室海报上的词语完全相同。那些打电话的人可能以为他们在说服别人，但干预措施真正的核心焦点其实是说服他们自己。这就是伪善范式，这增加了他们去投票、而不会让下雨天、酷暑天气或者他们必须开车多走几英里路才能到达投票地点等任何因素阻碍他们的可能性
What I just now got through telling you about your brothers and sisters and I want you to say to them and make sure you use these exact words Make sure you vote if I can do it, so can you. And they did it. They said, if I can do it, so can you, which is the exact same words that were on the poster in the shower room. The people making the phone calls may have believed they were convincing others, but the real focus of the intervention was to convince themselves. That's the hypocrisy paradigm, and that increases the probability that they will vote and not let rainy weather or extra hot weather, or the fact that they have to drive an extra few miles to get to a voting situation that none of that will
我刚刚对你说的关于你的兄弟姐妹的事，我希望你对他们说，并确保你用这些确切的词：确保你去投票，如果我能做到，你也能。他们照做了。他们说，如果我能做到，你也能，这与淋浴房海报上的词完全一样。打电话的人可能认为他们在说服别人，但干预的真正重点是说服他们自己。这就是伪善范式，这增加了他们投票的可能性，不会让雨天、酷暑，或者他们必须多开几英里路去投票站等因素阻碍他们。
discourage them. They might even have to lose a day's work, but in order to avoid being a hypocrite, my prediction is that a great number of people, a high percentage, will vote. And in every single one of the swing states, the percentage of black voters capable of voting who actually voted in Obama's second election, exceeded the percentage who even voted in his first election. It wasn't a well-designed, well-controlled experiment, of course. But I think it's pretty good evidence that the hypocrisy paradigm worked in getting out the vote. And so in all the in these cases here, the goal is not so much that people are convincing others, but that by trying to evangelize to others,
阻止他们。他们甚至可能不得不请一天假，但为了避免成为伪君子，我的预测是，会有大量的人，很高比例的人，会去投票。在每一个摇摆州，奥巴马第二次竞选时，有资格投票并实际投票的黑人选民的比例，超过了他在第一次竞选时投票的比例。当然，这不是一个精心设计、精心控制的实验。但我认为这是很好的证据，证明了伪君子范式在动员投票方面发挥了作用。所以在所有这些情况下，其目标与其说是让人去说服别人，不如说是通过试图向别人宣传，
you end up convincing yourself. That's the central idea here. Exactly, and you can see that it follows from in trying to convince somebody else that it's an interesting thing, you end up convincing yourself. That's powerful. It's also worth pointing out that in all three of these examples that we've looked at,
你最终说服了自己。这就是这里的核心思想。完全正确，你可以看到，正是通过试图说服别人这是一件有趣的事，你最终说服了自己。这很有力量。同样值得指出的是，在我们看过的这三个例子中，
the condom study regarding stopping the HIV virus and AIDS, the shower study of taking shorter showers in conserving water, turning out to vote. In all these cases, you're actually closing the gap between what people already say their views are and their behavior. So, you're not convincing people who are against conserving water to conserve water. You're not convincing people who don't want to vote to vote. You're just telling people, if you already believe this, let's close the gap between your intention and your action. That's exactly right. You've really hit the nail on the head there. We're not changing any opinion or any attitudes. We're simply making sure
关于阻止艾滋病毒和艾滋病的避孕套研究，关于洗短一点的澡以节约用水的淋浴研究，以及出来投票。在所有这些情况下，你实际上是在缩小人们已经表达的观点与他们的行为之间的差距。所以，你不是在说服那些反对节水的人去节水。你不是在说服那些不想投票的人去投票。你只是在告诉人们，如果你已经相信了这一点，让我们缩小你的意图和行动之间的差距。完全正确。你真的切中要害了。我们没有改变任何观点或态度。我们只是确保
we convert their own attitude into action. Can you think of examples in your own life, in your personal relationships, in your exchanges with your wife maybe, where you say and do something and you realize, you know, 30 minutes later, I'm actually, you know, this was actually cognitive dissonance at work, and you're actually able to self-correct. Every married couple has things that they disagree on, and this is an intimate relationship that's fraught with difficulties, and that's why the divorce rate is as high as it is.
我们将他们自己的态度转化为行动。你能想到你自己的生活中、你的个人关系中、或者与你太太的交流中，有什么例子吗？当时你说了或做了某些事，然后在30分钟后你意识到，你知道的，这其实是认知失调在起作用，而你实际上能够自我纠正。每对已婚夫妇都有意见不合的事情，这是一段充满困难的亲密关系，这也是为什么离婚率这么高的原因。
It's somewhere around 50 percent, but it's more difficult than that because the percentage of unhappy marriages between two people who don't get divorced is quite high also. And the question for me is to be able to have a discussion with my wife that becomes an argument about something we disagree on, and then to step back and to ask myself, now, was I simply protecting my ego here? Or is this something that is important in and of itself, and my position on this topic is really important and true in and of itself.
离婚率在50%左右，但情况比这更困难，因为没有离婚的两个人之间不美满婚姻的比例也很高。对我的问题是，能够与我太太进行一场讨论，演变成一场关于我们意见不合的事情的争论，然后退一步问自己，刚才我只是在保护我的自我在吗？还是这件事本身就很重要，我对这个话题的立场本身就是非常重要且真实的。
And under close scrutiny, if I decide I think you were just protecting your ego, then to go back and apologize and say, you know, I was wrong on that one. I think you made the right choice. I think I was doing something else. I was reducing, doesn't it? For me, there's nothing that feels better than to be able to do that. And to be living among people, my wife and my kids,
在仔细审视之后，如果我决定我认为你刚才只是在保护你的自我，那么就回去道歉并说，你知道，我在那件事上弄错了。我认为你做出了正确的选择。我想我当时在做别的事。我在减少失调，不是吗？对我来说，没有什么比能够做到这一点感觉更好的了。生活在这样的人中间，我的太太和我的孩子，
also, who are capable of doing that. It really does make for a much more exciting and much more realistic relationship. Since Elliott developed a theory with his mentor, Leon Festinger, over six decades ago, the term cognitive dissonance has become an everyday term in households and in organizations. I asked Elliott what he made of the ubiquitous use of the term in everyday parlance. I think we are living in a time now. This is the time of cognitive dissonance. You know, the term cognitive dissonance 20 years ago was unknown to the general public.
他们也能够做到这一点。这确实让关系变得更加精彩、更加现实。自从埃利奥特六十多年前与他的导师利昂·费斯廷格共同提出这个理论以来，认知失调这个词已经成为家庭和组织中的日常用语。我问埃利奥特，他对这个词在日常语境中的无处不在有什么看法。我认为我们现在正生活在一个时代。这就是认知失调的时代。你知道，二十年前认知失调这个词对公众来说是未知的。
Now you see it every time you pick up a newspaper or a magazine or go on television or on the internet, it becomes a concept that's very applicable. This is the time of cognitive dissonance where politically and with the COVID crisis, the pandemic, we're living in a world now, more so than ever, I think, where they're using cognitive distance theory to understand the things that are going on around us is terribly important. In the book that you wrote with Carol, Carol Tabris, mistakes were made but not by me, you cite work looking at marriages, looking at how regardless of how marriages turn out, people tell stories that explain sort of why it is they've ended up the way they have.
现在你每次拿起报纸、杂志，或者看电视、上网，都能看到它，它成了一个非常适用的概念。这就是认知失调的时代，无论是在政治上还是在新冠危机、大流行期间，我们现在生活在一个前所未有的世界里，我认为，利用认知失调理论来理解我们周围发生的事情是极其重要的。在你和卡罗尔（卡罗尔·塔布里斯）合著的书《错不在我》中，你们引用了关于婚姻的研究，研究了无论婚姻结局如何，人们如何讲述故事来解释他们最终走到这一步的原因。
And this is I think that the interesting and fascinating thing about cognitive dissonance, which is people sometimes use cognitive dissonance almost as a pejorative as a form of name calling. We basically say, our opponents are engaged in cognitive dissonance. But the fascinating thing I think about the work that you and others have done is that it actually doesn't matter which course of life you choose.
我认为这是认知失调有趣且迷人的地方，人们有时会把认知失调当作贬义词或贴标签的形式。我们基本上会说，我们的对手陷入了认知失调。但我认为，你和其他人所做的工作最迷人的地方在于，你选择哪种生活轨迹其实并不重要。
Cognitive dissonance is still probably going to be at play. You have a happy marriage. You're going to tell yourself a story about why you have a happy marriage. But the same is true also if you have an unhappy marriage. Yeah, it's true. But if you have a happy marriage, you don't need a story. Things are just working out. If you have an unhappy marriage, you need a story.
认知失调可能仍然在起作用。你有一段美满的婚姻。你会给自己讲一个关于为什么你有一段美满婚姻的故事。但如果你有一段不美满的婚姻，情况也是如此。是的，确实如此。但如果你有一段美满的婚姻，你就不需要故事。事情很顺利。如果你有一段不美满的婚姻，你需要一个故事。
You need a story as to why you're staying in it. You need a story as to why you're ending it. And chances are, the story is very self-enhancing. I recently wrote an autobiography, and writing that autobiography was such a great learning experience because as soon as I started it, I realized that the trap that any person writing an autobiography falls into, is to be reducing dissonance all the time, but not telling anybody that you're reducing dissonance.
你需要一个关于你为什么要维持它的故事。你需要一个关于你为什么要结束它的故事。而且很有可能，这个故事是非常自我美化的。我最近写了一本自传，写那本自传是一次非常棒的学习经历，因为我刚一动笔就意识到，任何写自传的人都会陷入的陷阱，就是一直在减少失调，却不告诉任何人你在减少失调。
The tendency is to always put yourself on the side of the angels when you're writing this stuff. And what I kept doing was trying to question myself, as is this the way it really happened? Or is this just a self-serving way of presenting myself? And I became my own severest critic and anything that didn't really ring 100% true, I discarded. And that's because I think my work on cognitive distance made me high-percentive to what we do all the time in self-presentation.
在写这些东西时，人们总是倾向于把自己放在天使的一边。我一直在做的是试图质问自己，事情真的是这样发生的吗？还是这只是我为了自我标榜而表现出来的方式？我成了自己最严厉的批评者，任何没有100%真实的事情都被我删掉了。这是因为我认为我对认知失调的研究让我对我们在自我呈现中时刻在做的事情保持了高度的敏感。
Even when we're presenting ourselves to ourselves, even if there is an audience for that. And that's a trap that's very, very important to try to avoid. Nobody succeeds 100%. I don't think I succeeded anywhere near 100%. But for when I read other people's autobiographies now that I've written one, I see it all the time. I see failures to examine that process. Psychologist Elliott Aronson's autobiography is called Not by Chance Alone, My Life as a Social Psychologist.
即使我们在向自己呈现自我时也是如此，即使这有观众。这是一个非常、非常重要、需要极力避免的陷阱。没有人能100%成功。我认为我远远没有达到100%的成功。但现在当我读别人的自传时，既然我自己也写过一本，我就到处都能看到这一点。我看到了未能审视这一过程的失败。心理学家埃利奥特·阿伦森的自传名为《绝非偶然：我的社会心理学家之旅》。
Elliott, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was a great, great pleasure to be with you. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero for this episode is Michael Reed. Michael works at SiriusXM, our ad sales partner, and helps to
埃利奥特，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。能和您在一起真是太高兴了。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥秋恩·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我们本集的无名英雄是迈克尔·里德。迈克尔在我们的广告销售合作伙伴 SiriusXM 工作，并协助
shape the advertising that you hear on Hidden Brain. Like many small independent companies, our advertising revenues keep the lights on. Michael has been a collaborative and helpful partner, especially during a time when advertising revenues have taken a serious hit across the media landscape. If you take it for granted, there will be a new Hidden brain episode in your feed every week. Michael is one of those unsung heroes who makes it happen. Thank you Michael. If you enjoyed our two-part conversation on Cochnid of Dissonance, please take a moment and share it with a few friends or family members. Word of math
塑造你在《隐藏的大脑》中听到的广告。像许多小型独立公司一样，我们的广告收入维持着我们的运转。迈克尔一直是一个合作且乐于助人的伙伴，特别是在广告收入在整个媒体格局中遭受严重打击的时期。如果你认为每周在你的订阅源里都会有一集新的《隐藏的大脑》是理所当然的话，迈克尔就是让这一切发生的无名英雄之一。谢谢你，迈克尔。如果你喜欢我们关于认知失调的两部分对话，请花一点时间把它分享给几个朋友或家人。口碑
recommendations make a huge difference in helping us connect new listeners with the ideas we explore on the show. I'm Shankar Vedanthan. See you soon. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
推荐对于帮助我们将新听众与我们在节目中探讨的思想联系起来起到了巨大的作用。我是尚卡尔·韦丹坦。我们很快再见。音乐本集目前没有评论。点击转录中的任意句子即可留下评论。